[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello wait let me turn this down there
we go
hi guys how are you sorry that took me
so long
I've just been I'm sure you've noticed
I've been like playing around with new
things um I wanted to like try streaming
to twitch but then I didn't want you
guys who don't use switch to like miss
out so I was like why not stream to both
so today I'm replaying hi Potter and the
Prisoner of Azkaban which is what you
guys asked for actually because I put
Paul on Twitter and yeah I'm actually
super excited cuz like I had a few games
up there was like amnesia
play more of court of Cthulhu and there
was like a mystery game as well but you
guys chose this one and it's gonna be
super nostalgic for me because I used to
play this game every Christmas cuz
there's a part where you get to ride
Buckbeak in the snow and like I don't
know no it's just very Christmasy for me
hmm so let me say hello sorry I was like
away cuz I won games max knows I mean
I've got apples and peanut butter hell
yes
hey wsg bwong hey mad sinner hey Connor
Ellis hey Michael tonic hey Ivan oh
mercy
hey gyein hey Tabriz hey Adonis
hey Bernie stars gaming so it took me a
while hey
took me a while you who's that the bacon
wheel Thank You bacon wheel for
following I was just about to say it
took me a while but like I was like
setting up all these widgets and trying
to like make sure that they were gonna
work for both YouTube and twitch so
whether you donate to me on Twitch or
have a stupid chat on youtube or you
follow me on Twitch or you subscribe to
me on youtube or you like we host or
whatever it should come up in the little
the little thing and also a present
should go in this right here cuz I was
like oh it's a Christmas stream and as
presents come down the Christmas tree ah
oh no I'm getting peanut butter
everywhere I knew what would happen
hey alex Williamson's blind adventures
lovely to see you here I don't think
I've seen you in like many live streams
actually but you always comment on my
videos thank you very much oh also that
reminds me a new video is coming at half
past 8:00 tonight oh you lucky ones
aren't you like I gotta like apologize
because this very long video but I think
it's entertaining I tried to make it as
insane as possible but hey that just
means that you have more stuff right
what's my twitch might which is yagna
annex which probably you put that in
like the description of the YouTube but
whatever we've already started now okay
so I'm just kind of looking I've also
got this but I don't know if these are
working are these working some of it's
working some of it's not working so I'm
not going to use it so I'm gonna be
streaming by the way every single day
this week oh my gosh well every working
day so Monday to Friday hey
some are so you will be seeing me a lot
more and I'll probably become more and
more used to the streaming thing peanut
butter is a mess this is just like me in
my life oh hey actual bird nose sorry he
isn't very attractive but this took me
so long to set up and I was like oh
hello by the way
I I did get a hacker I don't know if you
noticed but I did get a haircut and I
was gonna go for like um bangs or
whatever you call them but then I kind
of flaked out and I just didn't commit
to it just like I just didn't commit and
yeah this is what I'm working with at
the moment
and I'm just like I'm just hoping you'll
grow fast because I can't really turn it
into a full fridge and I don't actually
think you fall for it and shoots me
anyway so I'm kind of glad that I didn't
commit
I think I wouldn't forget it because I
already look pretty young and I I feel
like this makes me look even younger so
um just trying to like trying to deal
with it right now
I don't really know like what it's doing
most of the time but yeah whatever we'll
we'll make it work
we'll make it work anyway this is just
hair why am I talking my hat let's play
the game cuz everyone's here and it's
working this is great this is great
twitch gang ah we've got everyone in the
same place oh this is so exciting
okay right let me just have one more
Apple piece and then we'll actually stop
playing oh gosh peter bar is so messy
it's so good though
all right
are you ready for a blast blast from the
past I am so ready
oh yeah but I'm this backup now
oh yeah sorry am I too loud I keep going
in the Reds when I'm screaming can't see
your money fringe okay
yeah just let me know hey ya good muffin
so I have played it a little bit the
other day but that was just to like make
sure that everything was okay hey s 69
bizzle that's a weird name but I ain't
no judge I'm good thank you how are you
right new games
look at those graphics
says he the Sirius Black has escaped
from the wizard prison Azkaban 12 years
ago black murdered 13 people with the
single girls well at least we'll be safe
on Hogwarts what's wrong Harry
wrong I overheard your dad talking about
Sirius Black last night the Ministry of
Magic inches after me
do you love their faces Oh Harry
you'll have to be really really careful
don't go looking for trouble I don't go
looking for trouble trouble usually and
the voice acting is so you don't want to
wait professor
I'm animation quality is excellent
yes it is all right Ron let's get on
this just got much to go that anyway
where could he gone do you guys see this
gathers you better hurry off that brats
hairy debris were about serious black
hairy don't worry I'm sure they'll catch
him soon
thank you such a scary man
the Dementor attack no well yes I'll be
sued Kappas who's in here
we got another oh we got slither and
they're looking for that rat if I were
you Harry wouldn't want Cruikshank's to
find it first
fine fine wait to be come from their way
and one touch of yours is of metal are
they
whoo-hoo thanks for following birdie
Stars game and their ham or mouse button
to activate your wand
keep holding while you move the mouse to
aim your want they can suddenly turn
into piranhas see what's that I want to
get up there it's shiny jump up to climb
it there's right right dad you lead the
way
walk forward towards the crate and click
the right mouse button to jump
a great-looking onion I'm glad you
follow me
oh wait wait now I can go and check out
that side something wicked stop that
shot oh my god are these controls so
difficult I don't actually think that
that is anything nope it's quite a feed
them ah okay I'm just made stupid Bertie
Botts I remember Romney's like obsessed
with bright Botts every flavour beans in
this game and you use him don't you to
find this sort of stuff in the show
going on Himani show us how it's done
you do you girl different oh my god too
many things are happening I don't
remember like the spells showing up like
icons but then I played it on the ps2
before
in a star that just up to this point
gals like I love the way Harry groans as
he drew a chump
how are you doing oh okay I'm staying
again breathing brawn you might think
about training your rods wow it's so
much of New York can you train a rat
cast at the same time to open it all
three of us I'll start and you to join
in okay name I'm Ron I think it's got a
gargoyles
posthumous a teapot and a secret area
like that
okay I really don't remember this
oh that was loads of fun
ricky-rock look from this will help us
get our strength back after that running
with those social pages
come on follow me
this
well look who it is
hottie in the weasel
reaches carriage did they probably the
only place you can find a friend
actually oh uh Oh monstrous looking book
actually I believe it's a copy of the
monster book of monsters promoted
[Music]
come on guys help me out
oh my god it's okay just scream though
run you really do need to work on the
accuracy of your spell-casting
a wizard can i love tractor please
we search around another Hogwarts we
could find all AG collectors cards what
[Music]
where am I I didn't actually listen to
Hermione oh is this one so Bert's the
favor the fearful 1014 to 1097 famous
for being so cowardly
he never ventured out of his house hide
when a defensive charm backfired and the
roof oh oh my god
you want to learn some lessons from that
guys don't ever be too scared to do what
you want to do cuz we're all gonna die
in the end anyways so
[Music]
give us a lot of trouble right
Dementors
[Music]
Oh God
yeah leave out Sauron cuz he's like how
do I move what I'm like what am i doing
I'm not moving what do I do
[Music]
guys this is just me or is this game
like completely different to the ps2
game now that I'm ready
not like complaining cuz it's nice to
play something different but I'm just
like so kind of the same
I still remember any of the actual games
they'd be another
what happened what was that thing and he
just goes to like walk okay it's looking
at one of the Dementors of the basket
battle we better head back
we'll be at Hogwarts in a few minutes
I'm sure you're right Harry I'm fine
okay well that was a dramatic start the
music
Harry's encounter with the dementia but
caused him new serious huh
other than a growing feeling of dread
with me friends hurried to their first
class of the term anxious to resume
their lessons I'm Professor Lupin your
new Defense Against the Dark Arts
teacher and my hero first lesson in both
the spell got a retractor ron weasley
would you please join me
[Music]
behind these lows better it spells look
can I just step through this door again
oh yeah I remember this so like every
time you go into a class you have to go
through some door and like pretty much
just try not to die and that's how you
pass a class all right Ron Ronald is
Jimmy boy absolutely welcome to the carp
a retractable challenge Ron Green
Lantern shield scattered throughout the
challenge some are wealthy find all 10
shields to earn a visit to the beam
bonus room if you don't find all the
shields or first time through you can
always come back complete the challenge
by collecting the final machines let's
get started our parrot rectum has two
primary uses to pull yourself towards
something or to pull something towards
you see if you can find a statue to cast
a spell out then watch what happens
whoop thanks for following me pillow -
nakorn fellow pilots unicorn a pillow -
hiccup I let you look on
exit you could also use carpe retract
him to pull certain leave us see if you
can find one on a wall and try it out
oh I don't worry about some now I never
got around to changing it cuz I was
trying to figure out all this stuff I'll
do that after it buncha fight time I
think I remember how to use these might
be non first the cast under fire on the
tile to make it bouncy
now leap onto the tile to spring into
the air remember click the right mouse
button to jump
carpe retractor and also be used to pull
those two answers and see if you can
find something to cause them Donna I
just want to do slowly for everything oh
[Music]
these movies you can jump over hits like
this one on hold down the forward arrow
key to run towards it when he dodged
continue holding me I found right now so
now what what I do
oh I think you're supposed to do that
nice got myself a new card she will see
who this is vampire sir Sir herbert von
d 1858 to 1889 short lived by our dead
standards victorian vampire who preyed
upon women in london during the 1880s
was subsequently captured and killed by
a special squad from the department for
the regulation and control of magical
creatures
[Music]
carpe retract them can also be used on
certain books
Pepito do I need to kill them the little
pity
[Music]
professor Liu Kim that thing doesn't
look very friendly that is an improv in
wizard crackers spells may not be
effective in this situation try not to
let the wizard crackers touch you while
they're in the air when they land you
can pick them up but be careful if you
are not quick enough the crackers will
explode okay see if you can pick up a
wizard clap for your throwing how do i
how do I figure it up again now let's
put your training to the test the testis
these are was a lot more than beans
[Music]
[Music]
like clicking like crazy
I need a capture card so I can play on
my PST games when you go to cake I'll
bet they're worth loves more than beans
in front of Jorge's shop okay long give
me things
Oh No the hell did I nearly just fall
down I can soar I nearly just fell down
there but oh well it's all blocked up
now
wait it doesn't open after you do this
maybe now nevermind oh yeah that's a
good question Joshua what what what like
house would you guys say you were in
Joshua says babe ankle Diane says
Gryffindor and Yaga muffin said that's
not a name sorry
not too sure about this
prednisone still have a shop yet what
did they make that shot wasn't illness
I'd tell my book go like cuz they
definitely didn't have it at the very
beginning it's okay girl we go yeah
it's an interesting mechanic I'm glad he
doesn't just set you down straight away
because that would be strong very hot
well wouldn't be that hard but this game
is for kids don't forget kids like puke
up puke it up so apparently they are
making like a proper new game
and I'm so excited because after this
game I mean I I'm pretty sure this
agency from the ps2 version because the
PSC one was amazing but after that one
they all went downhill
to be fair I never played the fifth one
but be careful
the portal was rendered some last
rictusempra to know what been cast again
is needed to knock the five gonna poop
fire at me I didn't hear what damn that
out
firepits to come get in it kidding
kidding
don't you dare to fire at me
can I
you know what now that I'm thinking
about I don't even know if we actually
ever finished the PSC game I know I got
to the bit where you're at the end and
like all of the Dementors are coming
towards Harry but yeah I don't think I
actually managed to get my Patronus
to like get them to go away and then I
just gave up I'm pretty sure
[Music]
let's get this now Oh Fred and George
left Hogwarts to make their shop and
order the Phoenix see that's that's two
two away from this one alex is a
Gryffindor
oh and hey Tom Tom Tom if you know this
game can you tell me is this different
from the ps2 version I'm playing the PC
version and I thought like obviously
there might be some like game mechanic
differences but like I feel like I'm
playing a completely new game and I
don't know if it's just because I
haven't played it in years and I'm just
I'm brewing it well so tell me you tell
me your thoughts
[Music]
down don't fire people meat
[Music]
where am I going now Oh God yes Joshua I
agree they should make a fantastic piece
although apparently in like the next
high pot game that they're making like
the real one there are gonna be a lot of
pieces like that I mainly focused
focused focused so I'm just hoping it's
gonna be like the old games where you
get to explore a lot and like do that's
a fun stuff for them yes I kind of
bought open well because I remember
playing the high points one two and
three and thinking they were like so
open world how do I get over there oh
I'm actually
how do I reach you how do I get up here
what is my okay
PC voters are most of the time different
dammit
okay I might actually just try to find
the ps2 version to play on here like at
some point during this week we'll see
we'll see if you guys want it
yes Yaga muffin you're right I'm a
Gryffindor which people hate you saying
but I am I'd say I was like in between
Gryffindor and like a ravenclaw but the
more I do the test and think about it
like I'm definitely more of a burrito
no wait hold up I'm on the back I didn't
get the thing no I didn't get the thing
I didn't get this bulls I'm not gonna
get a grade now it's me like I'm not a
ravenclaw hey where did you say
what's a pan get me over there please
how how
okay so I think I can kind of swing on
these things no wow
also what are a second
wait is that to that name how do I
wish I could just swing but I can help
how everyone is showing the test now do
the test guys tell me what you are
how do you get up there okay hold up my
name
I love wrong LeBron was like my favorite
character although my friends used to
say I reminded them of oh hello of
[Music]
Hermione could you get no no I wanna get
this
to know what to do with that what does
that do you
where does that rope go oh okay
[Music]
Oh cheering on twitch and abstruse
doesn't work as well what do you mean
what is cheering I feel like such a noob
well what is the order though what do
you mean
is there anything that I can do to help
with that
so when I was doing my final year I
would just put on the oh yeah got to
pick up the things I thought I would put
on the soundtrack to these games and it
would just help help me through my
stress the uni stress die die disappear
blow up I don't know do whatever you do
where's my health spa oh there is
somebody get get that frog and open it
again why not
[Music]
that's what is it gonna open Oh Oh slow
down here Oh secrets apparently you are
too nice and smart to be a raisin for
but Ravenclaw's are smart but then you
say according to Ruina most of the girls
in the house would mean no one wait
where we know is that in the mobile game
[Music]
I guess they're just probably very
competitive which way am I going okay
nope oh of course that's why I came
[Music]
when am I gonna get to explore the
grounds please
[Music]
[Music]
oh okay so they you're like telling them
but because they won't gropes they just
do stuff oh no way she can't be
well darlin
unfortunately you didn't find all of the
challenges you'll need all ten to unlock
the beam bonus room I don't care about
anything
what donors just another girl once they
don't let me do all that again that was
fantastic
well done one was so proud of you
where are we these doors will let us
back into any small challenge we've
completed you can have another gun you
can't be attracting change if you like
Ron no thanks we could go exploring yeah
lead the way Ron that's what I want to
do
look at Yaga muffin giving us all these
all these backstories Helena ravenclaw
is Runa broken Klaus daughter and she is
the house ghost of Ravenclaw and I think
you ever got to properly see the house
ghost of Ravenclaw in the films or
anything did you
just that challenge isn't open yet it's
okay
we don't want charges we're gonna go
explore a chamber I've heard about this
room these portraits provide shortcuts
to every floor in the castle I wonder
how we can get the password Harry Potter
just the person I was looking for hello
Brett Where's George
upstairs minding the shop early
Christmas present for you Harry
it's the
for is map it'll help you find your way
around Hogwarts
Wow Thanks bread press the tab key on
your keyboard to bring up this map at
any time
come on follow me upstairs I'll lead you
to the shop
yeah you saw marina
but that wasn't what's up Halla nuts
your waiting time to chat
I've got your Sabbath better to be shop
since oh I don't know
are you which way is it
no you're not these are the challenge
rooms you lied to me
he's just like hello
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's super fast
nuts like its marked
[Music]
was this hey Harry
ravenclaw hello
wanna buy collector's car Terry
sure why not healed thanks for not like
a sweet Emily I think we'll need to buy
a password from Fred in Georgia
okay I'm not gonna mime it's you're
waiting horses I'm a bit disappointed
I'm definitely gonna have to find the
PST version but we're gonna carry on
that's something I'm glad to see you're
feeling better
thanks for the follower simply ravenclaw
are probably aware the Dementors of
Azkaban I here at Hogwarts and haber
only of magic business whole bet Sirius
Black stays well clear of Hogwarts with
those demented lurking about
come on that George is waiting at the
shop follow me Lutz what does he do then
let's you're waiting for isn't it I
guess we best get up to his shop soon
hello I've got some collectors I got
some collectors cards for sale
Ventus sure oh boy
I just given really a lot of my beans
[Music]
but you in two major to shock yet I
heard they've got loads of great stuff
this year I'm heading up there right
yea-ah we're in Gryffindor Tower so
their shop is
well see you later just remembered I've
got to see Professor McGonagall about
something this is the one where she has
a time Turner right hello Harry
welcome to our shop Wow no come to any
onto the Lance your fancy will tell you
what's what and how much it costs and
it's red cereal logics comment about how
this is an entirely different game but
it still doesn't seem too bad so we're
still gonna play but I still really want
to play the ps2 ones like maybe maybe
tomorrow something I'm playing ok there
are enough Bertie Botts beans to buy
that heart
oh damn it cuz I just bought the other
thing looks like you don't have enough
Bertie Botts beans to buy that hurry can
I give you my other stuff I picked up my
pumpkin pies and whatever sorry Harry
can't stick around to chat I've got a
whole pocket for the Bertie Botts beans
I've been trying to chat with ya
looks like you don't have enough Bertie
Botts beans to buy that Harry ok great I
can't afford anything but I don't really
need anything so it looks like you don't
have enough Bertie Botts beans to buy
that Harry
well then this one afraid you don't have
enough pumpkin pasties on Annie's
pumpkin pasties ICS looks like you don't
have enough Bertie Botts beans to buy
that hairy troll in the dungeon what is
this oh now there's a very special
collector's card Harry will give it to
you for free if you can collect all the
other cards in the set
come again anytime Harry yeah
Laurence can't youtube that sonny wilson
well the Harry Potter game that leaked
the other day oh my god
peeps one of the house jump scare from
peace away so they've got no passwords
so they can't use the portal shorty cats
hey paper right let's toss together and
reach that pest of a poltergeist a
lesson Ron get out the frickin way
Ron you're facing the wrong way
Ronald man do things mom you're freaking
idiot what are you doing Ronald was come
on let's give it a go
where ever wants me to play the ps1
version of the first game I could but
I've already want to play this game I
know anyone play PST ventures this game
this was like my game this is like my
favorite game it's all this time to care
of magical creatures pause okay let's go
go check out hybrid commands we launched
a dog
[Music]
I don't care about you so high
that's great never go together come on
fire me
[Music]
Michael what did you miss
Robo actually he missed me kappa in
class
finding the shop no no much no much too
warm I did what oh this is weird our
most PC games if you press hold shift
you've run and this one you walk so I
guess it's more cinematic if you hold
shift where are we going guys what's
what's the plan
I forgot oh hey great so he's gonna be
outside right let's go
yeah um I always forget about peeves
until I pay the games and I'm like oh
yeah cuz I read all the books as well
it's so weird that he just wasn't in the
films at all but I get it you can't have
everything you heard what was that pan
it just went into his head and then was
like changed to the front of you see
alright it's a level cinematic walking
look at that water
okay let's go where's the long-ass
bridge he hurry over here yes not able
to buy anything but I haven't beaten up
beans
well why call me over then they know who
beans being left on the side high genic
[Music]
none and also I loved this game the
third game on the ps2 because you can
play as like any one way so I'd love
just lucky like in between different
characters Oh save but let's go to
Hagrid's class hopefully you can go and
see hug hug hug hug
well obviously we'll see hug when I
meant Buckbeak which was never Carroll's
magical creatures class is just two
decades and that must be a pixie
infestation when you three have finished
dealing with the Pixies care of magical
creatures classes this way it's up to
you how we can explore for a bit all
follow Neville to class what should we
do guys to explore for a bit so we go
kill it Pixies or should we just go
straight to hopefully see Buckbeak I'm
gonna get over here fast anyways
I want to add on some dragon yeah I know
stop reminding me how cool I am
it's like real life okay
I thought I could get these I'm just
wrecking Hagrid's pumpkin patch sorry
but I need some beans it's a magic patch
anyway I could just stay here for hours
and just gain all of the beans but it
would take forever one night anyway
now this is like the PC game but I do
have PSX so I'm gonna look for the PST
game
[Music]
it's a ps4 version no I don't think so I
mean I think the last game was ps3 oh
wait I can't member bug beat class seen
as if money would skip class for this
okay
I'm guessing that let's go straight to
class pixel definition Hagrid doesn't
expect us to it's going good
this dusting feature welcome to care of
magical creatures class hey [ __ ] me
juice you too Bobby he's a hypocrite
today we'll be learning how to write it
please let me friend Bobby pleasingly
friend okay please happy family
he won't have me back that filthy beast
hello baby there's a good boy
your goal is to fly through enough bats
to beat the top number on those little
bats in the bags you're ready just like
the right Mouse well to the images by
flag oh yes how do how do i do things
okay
oh yeah no no no go down I miss ah I am
no grace I have no grace okay go down go
down
oh no I'm sorry bug week oh wait this
pretty they're like in the PST game you
can have all of this to fly rod go down
go down but you could land on the castle
which is pretty cool and like I say it
got pretty snowy at one point um who's
really fun
[Music]
[Music]
are you all singing along I hope you up
if you know this here balls I hurt his
head
the last ones fine a collector's card
that was really well done Mary Hart from
when you need to talk to our goal
there's five courses to fly in all and
you can win a collector's card on each
of them I bet you're not dangerous at
all are you you great ugly image look at
me it's killed me you're not dying
do you think you'll be all right
of course Madam Pomfrey can make cuts in
about ever anyone to find out who did
the voice
[Music]
and he was worried about the cockroach
where'd hermione go anyway
it's nearly time for Transfiguration
class keeps you ready for class are you
all right what happened I'm just a bit
tired that's all
we'd better get up to the first floor
I'll be late for Transfiguration we can
take the bus plot portrait shortcut haze
on Thursdays you lead the way Harry
right first movement ones be great best
line ever look at me it scared me can
you not see
which one's Transfiguration class I
wasn't listening what what the hell
change our cheese charmer cheese charmer
do you want to replay the carpets rectum
challenge Ron this challenge is locked
Wow
thank you so much Tom Park I really
appreciate the donation I used to wait
what I used to do this I can't even see
myself right now so even if you can't
see what I do I used to do like a little
robot move for everyone so this is yours
I can't even do other your lights coming
up on the screen by the way they're best
be the best be - I set it up something
our neighbors and who should push these
go into a sea serpent
I love sea serpents oh it was
what are we doing I don't know I'm just
gonna walk around and get lost oh no I
can't afford your same major don't think
we can do here not a little room can I
turn the fire on they light a fire with
my magic no the portraits don't even
talk in this game truth about you
so dramatic okay
as you don't know where I'm going
I know I need to go to a less what
lesson am I going to what is this is
this your first stream on Twitch no i've
streamed before on twitch but just not
very often and not like properly this is
my first line if we want to see what's
behind his portrait we'll have to buy
the password from Fred and George a shop
to buy a password oh my gosh boy looking
ok it's weasel grunge is gone suck it
out I bet we can beat him if we all cast
at once tearing it down
friendship overall playmates
[Music]
I can't remember what peeves did in the
book but I know he had some pivotal
moments I want to say that he led the
troll into the castle who's chucking
pellets this isn't even hurting him
isn't easily
[Music]
I mean we have to do it together but
maybe you have to wait to a certain
point what why isn't your help going
down okay I think I have to get the
armor away from them
[Music]
okay I think the AMA was supposed to be
pulled off I'm so confused there we go
you were brilliant rod it's easy to be
brilliant when you're scared half to
death really does he never worked for me
in my life he's has probably made us
late pumpkin pies I still have never had
a pumpkin pie on my entire life and that
makes me really sad Oh I favor found the
glasses into Transfiguration class one
of the most advanced Transfiguration
spells enables a wizard to become an
animagus an Imagi can transform
themselves into animals and then back
into people for example McGonagall are
werewolves not a match I know they're
not an Imagi I turn into animals at will
and werewolves cannot control it's nice
it's good to know everything is popping
up all right thanks bloom I know that
faceless the DRA conifers and leper for
spells Miss Granger perhaps you'd grease
the class by having a go at the end yeah
I decided Camilla this is definitely not
a new game through this door then let's
begin I want to wake up with it this
bleak
not before the transformation of a small
apply not play IDR to because I can't
afford time aside no one has money yet
people at stir as soon as they get money
I'm here alone for the longer screams
please press the edge money go if you
complete the task at hand with the
rabbit reverse spell will stop on its
own what am I supposed to be
[Music]
what am i doing what is my what is my
bunny task to jump on your head ah way
rabbit holes throughout the challenge
Miss Granger
if a home rule is blocked by grass click
the left mouse button to make the rabbit
chew through the vegetation to chew
through the grass yep got it first time
when done hey thanks for 6
Dravid goo Berlin and if it's a show the
rabbit on top of the dirt and press the
left mouse button to begin digging right
use the left mouse button to chew or dig
that mascot it's too hard it is Granger
thanks bunny bun-buns
but that wasn't quite animagus because I
turn into I will have it we're learning
[Music]
[Music]
like in the PSD when you had that fire
spa didn't you and you could like set
fire some more oh I can't wait okay
let's go let's go no no no
[Music]
get all of these eggs
this is punny what is not backing up
backin up backin up backin up
whoo
[Music]
[Music]
wait but there was another another bunny
button so I wanna do again
press the other bunny button oh it
wasn't a bunny button
it was simply how do I stop casting this
spell I guess I just have to stand here
again oh oh oh well
[Music]
just carry on the game as the bunny head
than you know eggs
I mean beans but they didn't like eggs
Easter eggs I need to how am I gonna get
up there
I mean I jump high but I don't jump that
high oh oh here we go woohoo is that a
buzzin
[Music]
no no no don't-don't-don't nope we're
not we are not done here yet how do I
get up there oh hey hey bunny looking at
me hmm how am I gonna mmm is there any
way that I can jump nope didn't even
jump yeah
how are you get oh I know maybe I get
there later on or maybe I get that bike
pressing this fund oh okay okay okay
[Music]
let's go into the come on bun go into
the well oh I missed one this is cool
you another game that I already want to
play actually it's American McGee's
Alice oh just stop playing old games
[Music]
hello perfect
where am I am I gonna become a tiger
Miss Granger to transform it into a
living in feature
what is this rabbit simulation it's cool
I like this game turnout then we'll play
again okay
now listen oh it's so cute
you will need to use the dragon to get
the fireball pick up their new flyer and
land on a platform and I mean a proof
you must like the torch to complete this
part of the challenge after doing Miss
Granger
click the spacebar to make the dragonfly
alright folks here to make the dragon
breathes fire I realized that I just I
never listen to anything that anyone
tells me in this game um let's try and
get all the eggs I got it she knows but
I I'm too busy flying so I'm just not
gonna eat ya
why are mine so derp at this it's okay
[Music]
I'm not the best at flying I have
noticed if you were an animal what
animal would you want to be and it has
to be something that is real right now
like you can't say a dragon
[Music]
whoo
[Music]
tonight I think
[Music]
Oh - kitchen away hold up let me try
again
splendid so proud we're gonna go break
in the fog wall again
I absolutely love the way that it works
the broody tickles me right
[Music]
do you guys want to know what the
mystery game was that I put on my
Twitter poem so I think I'm gonna have
to pay that as well I think this week
it's gonna be mainly me playing like my
childhood game just cuz it's Christmas
and I don't know I feel like that's what
you're supposed to do Christmas or at
least that's what I have always done at
Christmas I just play really old school
games it makes me feel like a kid again
I guess that's one of the reasons why I
do like a cat or dog they live inside
and get loved for doing basically
nothing this is this is true I mean did
you do things they're just like well
yeah no they're just they're just cute
without even trying that's what they do
also dogs just like love you on
condition which is the door and to be
fair my cat did as well
my cat was like she's some meow on my
door at 7 a.m. 7 a.m. on the weekend
ooh adonus would be a wolf and Yaga
muffin would be a penguin Michael would
be a human well you are what you have
always wanted to be well done proud of
you
okay so we got ourselves a bunny hole
ready bunnies
[Music]
oh yeah Joshua well if you guys are
actually happy with me playing my
childhood games all week then I will
play Beyond Good and Evil because I have
it on Steam anyway so and just play
there I'm gonna have one day on Thursday
playing a little multiplayer game
probably dead by daylight with my good
friend tongue who is zero logic who is
in the chat right now so we'll have a
little lot of fun there but then every
other day yeah it would be nice just
play like an old-school game so one day
could be fun good Nebo another day if I
can find it can be this game with a ps2
I've also got my little mystery game
that I really cover way to play cuz it
was one of my favorite games and no one
even knows it exists
well very few people do I think I might
like one of the person that knows that
this game exists and I got extremely
funny but what am i doing oh no now they
have wings I know I know we need to find
you some fireballs so once I fire up one
guy does that mean that I have to go
through this whole process again no can
I just stay here
I guess we're best by now
oh my gosh these controls oh don't bring
me back to the beginning good good good
I love this little dragon that's the way
you walk so I'm just like ah so much so
cute I won't one go down oops oh hey
this is where I'll be going next a chest
[Music]
how does she receive these eggs if the
dragon picks them up it doesn't really
make any sense but I'm not gonna
question it just in case
oh no okay let's fly
by pixel definitions and thank you so
much for for watching hopefully I'll see
you next time I will definitely buy Red
Dead Redemption to gun Miller when I
when I have the money I'm so excited to
play though because I've just I've only
heard good things
only good things ah I can't see cuz
these wild plants is so big yes I
finished god of war - that was amazing
god of war - god of war although I
haven't like finished finished
I mean I've still got the slow quests
and stuff still haven't defeated all the
Valkyries or freed all of our careers
yet so I still got stuff to do
but I've finished the main story which
was so good we can talk about that on
Thursday and I can totally see why one
game of the year where
[Music]
my playin like okay so if I move them
around the top one the top one the top
one can I not do the top I don't think I
can actually do the table
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
interesting though I'm confused by this
I can't seem to get that oh my gosh I
can't get the top one okay great
it's just really bad mechanics and I'm
not even gonna try and get that last
chest this Miss Granger is abundant a
bunch of ugly expel of howler snail that
you will need to provide you can cursed
rictusempra understand about the I think
is it just me or does it sound right up
on top of it to see if dubstep said
award
so what did she say I think I think I
have to jump on it I am Mario now
[Music]
[Music]
met some more I see you've like put a
link in the chat but I can't click on it
but zero logic said it's the mobile game
so basically that this new game that got
leaked the other week the new high
Potter game they got leaked you won't be
able to find it anywhere now because
they've taken it down everywhere but
it's not gonna be available for I don't
know at least like another year or so so
it's not out yet oh gosh don't like jump
that's not how this works
yeah
[Music]
cool
all right where it's on old whoa hello
where's our little bunny Larry
no-no-no
[Music]
am I married I am married to my career
sad oh wait what was that
silver cell 78 thank you so much for
following and welcome
[Music]
she's married to videogames okay that's
that's a much better answer
I mean I'm to be fed that kind of is my
career answer so hey happy days these
guys
[Music]
I love how these potions are like half
the size of them it's not bigger and
they're just yanking them out of there
but like I have no idea
oh wow this game is I just don't know
how you could die um yeah well unless
you like me and you just fall off the
side but you know I mean in the battles
we'll see it might get hotter it's weird
thinks it this really shows that back in
the day console was the place to buy
your games and stuff like people didn't
really focus on PC games cuz this was
the PC game and it's it's fun but it's
got nothing on the console game but then
again I do have that you know it does
have been a static value for me and now
PC games are like just as well I mean
they'll be the same game I guess it's
the one that you get on the console but
PC games are even more superior because
you've been like mod them and stuff
what hurt me there are so many rubber
hose okay
[Music]
[Music]
where to go sinking
oh I thought it'd be a bunny I guess I
might change after then it let go my gun
that's a big keyhole back I'm still
nothing
do
[Music]
but standing in my fire oh cool okay
[Music]
wherewhere was that it's back here
[Music]
hmm
oh where can I go oh okay well that
worked nice so where is the bunny but
you will need to connect all ten
challenges to earn a visit to the bean
bonus room don't care take the challenge
again any time you please
Thank You Professor McGonagall you can
be sad too nugget oh oh thank you hero
of time that's actually super helpful
about the controller using D asked for
tool okay I'll have to remember that you
are cuz yeah I've I've got a game that I
really want to play but I've been trying
to use the fry to make the keyboard
control not
sucky and it's pretty hard so if I can
do that so pretty tropical dragon oh you
can have another go the challenge if you
like mining we can come back
DeSilva soul you appear in this game I
don't know the name but it's about
perfection I can't tell if you if you're
trolling on up
[Music]
okay guys time for a little break I will
be right back oh you go I have a little
scream for her and everything
you
you
I'm back
rejecting Mia
but mmm we are same Oh silver salt I'm
not trolling I'm only asking because I
like the game well I only said I thought
you were trolling cuz um I made the game
so if you want to like check out more
about the game you can see it all on on
my youtube channel I'm actually in the
middle of updating it for Christmas so
that there's gonna be like a Mac version
and there's a Linux version but I'm
trying to like add some extra bits to it
and fix some bugs as well before I do
the next release so yeah I think
actually I've got to do that tomorrow
before tomorrows stream and tonight I've
been I've been working a lot on my EP
trying to get that out I'm trying to get
the designs and stuff done so that's
what I've been doing today and I need to
when the stream ends which will probably
be in like half an hour's and things I
make dinner too but yeah so thank you um
but yeah I just I I was like are you are
you talking or not VI I made it
Oh the portable mister has to go and
recite poetry and joy sounds fun
okay what's the plan now run run run run
run run run run get out of the way I
think I'm gonna get another weak body
great story I was excited to be playing
in the first Quidditch match of the year
[Music]
did Jill pixels Perry came away from the
fall without injury but he resolved to
confront his fear of the Dementors
professor blue Pete offered to help him
with aunt Ida mental lessons he asked
Lupin about Sirius Black the man who had
been his father's best friend and had
betrayed both James and Lily to
Voldemort the professor seemed reluctant
to discuss the matter we better get on
with your hand'd a mentor lessons hurry
now we obviously can't bring a real to
mentor into the castle so we'll make do
with a Bhagat
the bullet will appear as that then you
fear the most which in your case honey
is fear and the fire voiced when dad's
first will practice what my bucket would
be in your one what do you think your
bullets would be hold down the left
mouse button to build the spells power
you'll see a ring of light move up your
arm for a perfect cast you must release
the spell just as the ring passes over
your wand give it a try the incantation
for the spell is expected expect oh
right two more like that and you're
ready perfect casts Harry you're ready
for the next stage of Alessi explore the
surrounding chambers and be ready to use
the Patronus charm I'm sorry what that
was expected patronum where was the stag
I'm so confused
oh the everyone's gone
I like how these ones are hiding and you
can see the hat and they're just like no
you can't see me so what am i doing okay
ah right the cabinets
[Music]
Oh a Dementor no basement attic in the
shape of a de mental to play on your
fears
[Music]
this makes Bobbitt the creatures
presence will likely kill cast a perfect
Patronus at Obama the decision before
the spell has time to wear off
it would seem mastica spell I'm just too
good at this game I'm such a good game
up oh oh it was a trap it was a trap it
was a trap
[Music]
you're the trap there's a trap in the
trap
the trap
I love that please forgive alex says my
burger to be a PE he mentors took you by
surprise you did brilliantly Thank You
professor lupin and if you're buggered
for the B what was your ridiculous spell
B how would you turn every year into
something but he asked professor dupit
if it was true that Sirius Black and
Harry's father had been a friend
professor median seemed disturbed by the
question he would only say that he had
no serious once I need to go and watch
all the Harry Potter films now please
Scottish dawn how do you know when I
stand on the floor dad's hair always
dad's hair you are not suggesting
Cruikshank's I just heard they go to
execute Bob beat because he attacked
Malfoy to be fair kids move runs and
she's a loud voice doing he's the one
who want to be punished
there must be something we can do and
appeal and appeal that's it
I'm sure I've read about a case of
hypocrite baiting we can look in the
library I'll come along but I've had it
for that monstrous cat of yours of ivy I
wonder where Madame pinson's
may be Crookshanks got her too I know
she'd let us look at those books on
Hippogriff meetings
it's and I never got to play credit
you'll section over there but it's
locked up I just realized I wanna play
Quidditch alright but let's just try to
do this without getting into trouble
trouble there says we'll get into
trouble
I think we made coca leaves a beautiful
like that for Harry Potter with all the
other
doo-doo-doo-doo maybe we'll find a way
to get us up for that legal section Ron
so we can actually use a switch and feel
like a proper witch or wizard using all
the correct movements and stuff I think
they tried to do something like that on
the phone where you had to know I think
you had to use your finger actually to
do the right spells but now with the
switch we could use the controllers
oh thank you
[Music]
oh I need those goods come up here as
well Hugh come me there you go
I'm not poor anymore I felt like 500
beans is how are we just gonna favor you
and Harry guarantee the lookout will
shelters madam Prince shows up
[Music]
[Music]
oh okay oh yeah
yeah it's it's athlete
it's get closer
[Music]
yeah I've got my little dragon friend
here what do I need him for okay this is
cute I love how it's a room and the
artwork is of the room itself very
interesting right what am i doing
oh well let's just become a dragon
there's got to be something around here
Alex said you're ridiculous spell for a
bee would be a guy in a bee suit I think
now be even more scary you'd like to
turn it into a natural man like a funny
grown man and like a bee suit that's
that's kind of I don't know I don't know
I just think that's freaky but each to
their own
wasn't there a guy like that in um the
Simpsons
what do you wanna set fire to the
fireplace I mean that would make sense
yeah Thank You dragon I think my bucket
would be shouting why are you watching
this stream I'm always like I spent do
you watch my wimpy careless man cuz
there's a lot of screaming in that he
said shouting I guess it did you find it
hey Nathan Shenton you just sent like a
blank message I didn't even know that
was possible pirates
hey how'd you do that we only just left
you well I took a shortcut
yeah bumblebee man from the cincin we do
is that his name oh thank you so much
Nathan I really appreciate just notice
one thing we have challenged blaster I
don't think I can see what you guys
actually say in the super chat and
that's Nathan didn't say anything
whatever it is let me know Nathan miss
you actually said some things through
the super chat or if you just donated
and if you do it thank you so much well
you did donate okay I got this it's like
something I did before and now I'm just
like oh my god it's stupid why waste
order here but but thank you thank you
thank you so much I hope everyone's
having a very nice holiday by the way
how about step back I can't believe this
only a week until Christmas like if you
guys finished all your shopping because
[Music]
all the most of its just been delivered
to the Internet to be fair what is this
well I guess you learn a collector's
card each time you defeat all the pages
oh thanks Michael it's Patti Nathan said
recently got a job so it's rest in cash
for one of my all-time favorite
youtubers bringing the best book in the
series thank you now I already
appreciate that and well done on the job
I hope it's one that you enjoy I hope
like you know you're feeling good in
your job and stuff sighing new jobs are
always fun cuz you're getting to meet
new people
and you can mess up and that's the fact
is she knew yeah I will will chop you
look at the yellow with there anything
will track after this and talk about
what games good playing this is just
making me so nostalgic for the ps2
version like I will I want so bad
hey Francisco
[Music]
I killed the evil book clown we back to
catch on to chance class again another
class I just want a Quidditch
[Music]
show me sequence
where
where are the secrets
oh there
[Music]
[Music]
cool
[Music]
first can't believe that they made the
fourth game and they just totally took
out all of the exploration I don't know
what they were thinking but if what I've
seen and heard about this next game it's
true that I'm a very very excited
because it should have all the elements
of exploration of obviously doing class
and things like that but also the
mystical creatures but you won't be
playing as higher or anything it'll be
kind of like the mobile game where you
create your own character which I don't
mind which way to transfer how do we
know what way to go there's the save
points absolutely everywhere
[Music]
huh
[Music]
where do we go for charms
yeah
[Music]
no we went from the classroom
[Music]
hey Michael injustice it's in a where
I'm going
wouldn't be down here because this would
be potions wouldn't but let's go anyway
if we want to see what's behind this
portrait well how are you husband or
girlfriend up towards your shop
hello Patsy buying a collector's card
Harry yeah I have money now why not oh
she's quite expensive but what I she
discovered the properties if we want to
see what's behind this portrait we'll
have to buy the password and Fred and
George's shot so it's not where potions
glasses oh no probably behind one of
these doors
I'm guessing paddy come over here
what to buy a collector's car paddy
they're all Scottish aside I'll buy it
enjoy the Cardinal
[Music]
but then again wasn't Hogwarts is
situated in Scotland right that's where
the Hogwarts Express is you can actually
go on it I've never been on of them I
won't open
where-where-where is John's show me the
way I'm so confused
[Music]
this way Dana just came from this way
[Music]
[Music]
look look look look okay yes this was
where Transfiguration was now it
so let's go up the staircase have a look
in here
[Music]
okay this is why I just came from
[Music]
do-do-do-do
[Music]
up another step away
yeah okay I like how you just have two
choices like do want the cinematic way
or just set the normal way
[Music]
[Music]
this is the pc1 michael injustice but
i've been saying throughout the whole
thing like i need to pay the pr2
to see what's behind this portrait
[Music]
[Music]
hi addy woman here
what hey you three looking for any
collectors cards again people don't like
me they just want me for my money right
it's a deal
cheers hi see you later oops
fancy buying a collector's card hey no
I'm just bought one of you right
see ya all right bye-bye
I think we'll need to bypass were made
in Georgia shop to see what's behind
this portrait see how do we buy
passwords then is this voice for the
relaxes no way I can't me because the
voice out to use is known good sorry
I highly doubt then guess not
thanks anyway okay how do i buy the
passwords
[Music]
from your shop Oh do I have to get the
corresponding cars may be extremely
valuable collector's card that one hate
to let it go really no thanks
don't know
[Music]
skip out too funny out whether she five
major
oh damn it I'm on the top floor star
flop can't be outside can i no no it's
not this way maybe it's outside nice gee
chief Reilly how many classes are you
taking this year she's calling her out
he's calling her out maybe it is on this
foot but I just come from this right
yeah I just did this one oh okay no I
didn't smoke this a frequent one put
your charms today we will learn a very
useful phrasing charm called
Glacius let's see who would like to
demonstrate Harry Potter just the face
every kid in class that is like a dream
thanks for coming Demetrius is useful
for have a nice sleep and hopefully see
you some other time in the week it's
begin with an episode salamander Shelby
oh these are in the PFT game from ok I
sneeze play that came out having it with
my teenage births the creature and its
fire give it a try
[Music]
oh poor thing
when am I gonna get anything okay this
is business the right arrow keys to turn
Harry plan through to slim down off you
go the end of the challenge
[Music]
choo-choo-choo
Oh
whoa nice okay
like
[Music]
oh you guys so nice
hey hey wait what is that what is that
oh it's a beans in the air oh okay
I'm gonna jump up there in a second I
see I see I see
I love how whenever you come across any
enemy even like one or two you instantly
get help
straight after so there is no excuse my
god there's a spatula there's no excuse
to die in this game and then I only meet
you only mean let's try this again okay
I need to hit something fun in the movie
and shook
this is very true
I'm missing it on I'm missing everything
oh my gosh
frogs are for health pumpkin pies and
worth more than beans but I think those
I'm not quite sure what those like green
things are where or what they even are
to be honest
these things
[Music]
wait
kill
what's down here
[Music]
oh wait well what about the other one
okay fine whatever
how do I get into you ah here we go
wow thanks you're puking over
[Music]
I don't know this way sure Wow such a
great fun I like these funny things
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so many safe points
[Music]
yeah
yeah this place is very dangerous for a
school but I mean you watch the films
right the games are just a step up I
guess
Wow I can go through I thought it's
gonna put me through that
I guess now what are we gonna have it ah
[Music]
wait I want to test in the app if I jump
this way well it still pushed me that
way
yup hey stir the roux
[Music]
which
michael says do you have a new
perspective on playing after making game
definitely everyone in my course at the
same thing once you learn kind of how to
make a game and stuff he started figure
out things like animation cues of
transitions I'd noticed that this game
pretty much has no like animation
transition so they'll loop but then when
they go back around they're just like
they just it's not smooth but it's funny
more come on then come on that's three
things
yeah make your faces
[Music]
wait Inez push me in the right place
what game is this this is high proton in
the prisoner of azkaban
form for the people I mistakenly thought
it would be very similar to the PST game
but it's - it's still not bad
oh yeah
Oh scheisse let's go left this time
go left
thanks for picking up this pumpkin pies
when I was not even near but I really
appreciate that
Oh get get it get my mitts like one
that's quite annoying but I see you
didn't find all of the challenge shields
well come back anytime you want to give
the challenge another try find all ten
shields and you'll get to go to the beam
bonus room do you get that nostalgic
feeling for playing our games and old
consoles hello yes I stick on my PhD of
my age dad's house and I went and
visited the other weekend all my PhD
games are there and I was like like did
anyone play a wait
you cannot another two and the glaziers
challenge if you want Harry no we can
come back later
let's go I wouldn't break with it
despite the dangerous visitor lurking
around Hogwarts Harry insisted on going
to visit agreed he was anxious to hear
the outcome of buck beaks trial
was that I think it was oh poor Hagrid
they carried out the execution Gavin
see ron Richards was innocent now it was
just your more orange hair that you saw
on the floor
I thought to you know see what that
texture on this on the tree it's so bad
[Music]
I'm not already here
I'm already out the whomping willow okay
then where does this wow that wasn't
only we're going to play that button and
sack but we've got to help wrong okay do
you hear something
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
get out the way then they're just
stunned nobody throws something at you
Italian spaghetti tree yes Maria I love
it
[Music]
wait dad the way Hermione's alyssum
still doesn't hate you
good she's learning she's learning from
her mistakes that's all you can ask from
anyone
[Music]
Oh Oh No
celebrating
you're quite impressive with that Glacia
start hurry
Thanks values what is this communication
right
that's why do they sound like cats when
I die okay
[Music]
it was a trap
hurry are you all right yeah fine
hi James thanks for coming keep looking
- you oh my god Michael oh did you play
King Kong on ps2 yes that is another
game that oh my gosh that's another game
I need to play that game was so good
very good especially the opening scene
was I just remember being so amazed by
or just being in the boat and watching
those you know Kirillov rocks the rocks
at like King Kong okay
what's the other ones os3
[Music]
don't know what that did that didn't
really do anything did it
maybe something I'll have one night do
all three
[Music]
brilliant that's a good truck ah wait
she was stuck in our animation
[Music]
I need Ron
[Music]
where is wrong
right oh gods are right
[Music]
[Music]
yes this again okay this was Aladdin
oh let him go damn yeah
choo-choo-choo-choo choo-choo-choo-choo
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm being quiet it's only because I'm
like I'm just like get me through this I
want to do everything I don't know if
you can actually pay for dish in this
game just where's that hmm I'm happy
that people want me play King Kong cuz
Joe wants me to play King Kong as well
and I quite wanna play King Kong WS GB
why doesn't she use a little more
because there is no luck on this but oh
you mean these two because there's two
dots so you need like two a little more
is at the same time I mean she could
just do what I'm one the one on the
other but I guess I don't know it's
magic doesn't work that way
just some of your time doesn't it dude
Hermione I need you to do this thing as
well oh gosh that one's done waiting
bust area to the car course of course
there's a frog like as soon as you get
into contact with anything scary this
frog what do you suppose dishes oh
Michael King Kong on the ps2 it was it
was so good for its for its time I mean
I haven't played this in so as a kid so
I'm probably picking out from my head
but I remember it being amazing and just
just imagine killing giant like
centipedes and dinosaurs and stuff
those giant centipedes sir they were
disgusting all the millipedes by them
they were gross boy hey guys I think I'm
just gonna try and brush to the end of
this and then um oh I see I see what
we're doing I think go for me chin up
and then I need to carry on with my
designs for the EP column so and but
before I go well we'll chat about what
games we should play Oh how's this way
during the week
[Music]
how do I move this one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh we need to move this down
[Music]
I'm Ashley suck
[Music]
huh oh you just can't see so I need to
do this one first
[Music]
and then bang and then you
[Music]
let's get lemon this is the challenge
guys will we make it
I don't know hurry in the morning
against the phone cats okay we made it
[Music]
where's the dog it's not a dog
[Music]
to be afraid Sirius Black is not what
you think he's and Scabbers he's not a
rat he's a wizard by the name of Peter
Pettigrew what watch just like in the
film guys just leaked in the bay
Pettigrew's and Anna mages
it wasn't Sirius Black who betrayed your
parents Harry
it was petting Peter Pettigrew have
gotta be betrayed James and Lily Potter
to Voldemort
he had also framed Sirius Black as
Voldemort spine
it was agreed that petty group would be
taken back to Hogwarts and turned over
to Professor Dumbledore but there was
one more secret to be revealed
[Music]
it's your right he's breathing at least
professor Lupin is a werewolf
I'll take thanks for watching bet plays
hopefully I'll see you again in the week
Oh scheisse the UM YouTube video is now
up guys so before I go well after I go
you guys
oh gosh next up
[Music]
expecto patronum
respective respondent who's next
you want some of my we expected patronum
because it doesn't even have the stag
where is the stag what is this game this
game hasn't even seen straight bar
hasn't even read the books oh my gosh it
opens me up upon Oh
that's just like the ethics Sonali guys
the epic finale
[Music]
[Music]
time
- intent
oh wait now this isn't the end Harry are
you all right what's happened it's
serious okay
where's Ron Madam Pomfrey says Ron will
be all right he just needs to rest
unfortunately Sirius Black is not faring
so well he's locked to the high tower
he'll be handed over to the Dementors
there's nothing I could do to stop it
but he's innocent
believe that's true what we need is more
time he's so sneaky he's like I would
break the rules but why should I break
the walls when I could get students to
do it for me so he doesn't have to get
in trouble I meant to tell you
eventually
Professor McGonagall let me borrow this
time Tyler I've been using it all yet to
go back in time so I can attend extra
lessons it really freaks me out who they
don't like you said to go and save Mike
me and then fly up the tower to rescue
serious but we must take care not to be
seen by early ourselves
the staggers during their trip Mountain
Time week that's true
I hope hope we do she at the time told
about the right amount
I kind of need to go but then I'm kind
of like curious about how this will come
about William let's find a way to get
there must be a way to make this
platform go up okay
ah perfect be careful now right kick
careful now
the door closed well there's got to be a
way out
[Music]
let's do this nice one to my knee you
arm the door but it's too likely to
reach hmm what about it
I go in there okay
does that help
perfect yeah hold tight I'll see what's
in there
oh go on then
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
just let me just draw it in here uh yeah
but it's just be smart money
[Applause]
dammit we need one of your bunnies yes
Temari is time traveling with her her
necklace I would so love that necklace
you know how much stuff you could get
done with our I wish I wanted time toner
toner
[Music]
[Music]
damn they're going everywhere
[Music]
cool
[Music]
my favorite thing about this game is
that how he shouts most of his lines try
true true words Joe mine and harmonious
shots and everything on to West
Australia - it's very true still using
the power of the time Turner hurry
towards the link
he kept alert he would cast the truly
spell now a snipe of the demented
at his father's company had James Potter
cast the spell but now it's time there
are you ready of the studio he hadn't
seen his father he had seen yourself
where is it should we decide
oh okay sar time now oh yeah I just kind
of like
out of my hair
[Music]
[Music]
gnarlie
go inside
LFO nobody moving hey Kara I am British
yeah Africa is up into the sky
today another film I don't remember
doing that
oh there is there is I'm happy now I'll
stop my whining I'll stop my complaining
I could have wrong Harry all those
Dementors that's very very advanced
magic well do it this time because I'd
already done it does that make sense
Harry we've got to rescue serious from
the tower and get back to the hospital
wing before anybody realizes we're
missing
let's go
insist the epic finale or did we just do
it this is gonna be cutscene
[Music]
[Music]
how serious
you'd better go they'll be here any
moment timber
so how could ever that go
[Music]
he's so happy views of Sirius Black's
escape spread to us
Harry Ron and Hermione kept what they
knew to themselves
besides it was the day of their final
exams and not only the friends
I don't know how you're possibly going
to pass your exams Ron you've hardly
studied a thing me you spend all that
time researching buckwheat stuff Ames
please Ron give me some credit
I used the time Tyler to study of course
and aiming for perfect marks of course
she's not a she but I'd news run your
car para tractable is that miss first
we'd better head up to Professor Lupin
class nope I am NOT doing this and that
is as much of the game as I'm going to
play I think I play through most of it
anyways but yeah I actually I actually
had quite a lot of fun playing that game
more fun than I think I realized oh I
thought I would do you actually
especially once I realize it's a PC when
I was like oh but um yeah do let me know
if you want to see me play the ps2
version I'll try and look for it online
so we can play it I do have other games
as well but of course we can play and
they will be back tomorrow and the next
day and the next day and the next day so
I've got my stream all set up now so I
shouldn't be late tomorrow yeah um
follow me on Twitter and I will put a
polyp because I'll need to see if I can
actually find the same on ps2 first
before obviously committing to playing
it so I'll see if I can find it and then
I'll put a poll tomorrow before the
stream starts which will be 5 p.m. gmt
and if not they'll be like some other
games that we can definitely play
together as well but steve was fun it
was it was a nice sweet little short
game and it was interesting to play a
high part of the game that hadn't played
before but he just made me really want
to play the original ps2 you are now
[Music]
yes exactly in Robins like the ps2
publicans of pure gold I mean the first
three and then there was Goblet of Fire
which was just was so bad so bad but
yeah follow me on Twitter
I'll just put I'll just put my Twitter
in here if you don't already have it
it's just I'm just yeah Gwen X on
absolutely everything and I will see you
tomorrow night so have a lovely day or
evening I will say goodbye to who I can
see in the chat so goodbye Robin goodbye
Joe Adams goodbye Michael injustice I
was about to say goodbye to myself but
that would be stupid
goodbye Alex Williamson's give
Williamson
it's your blind adventures what time's
your stream going to be tomorrow in EST
I'm not sure just Google 5 p.m. GMT in
the STM I'm sure Joey goodbye Diane
goodbye tybor Thibault tie ball goodbye
mantis goodbye Michael
goodbye WS just be one goodbye I think
red plies already left anyways so and
goodbye to anyone who is watching but
isn't in the chat right now thank you so
much for watching
I already appreciate it yeah and I'm so
happy to be back as well I'm gonna say
I'm really sorry about not being around
for a while I just work I've just been
working and trying to find like a job
and stuff I've been working trying to
find a job that doesn't make sense but I
had like part time kind of freelance
worked there obviously would only last
for like a week or something but I've
been trying to look for something more
stable and I found I found it and I kind
of explained that in my latest youtube
video which I will quickly get up for
you so that you can
have a little more of that if you want
to watch some more after this
so oh yeah
got the call of cthulhu son now do next
tomorrow I will make a thumbnail both
for the live stream but yes sir here is
oh wait now they're productive
here
that's the link to the new video so you
can watch that if you want some more yak
me so yeah have a lovely day or evening
I'll see you tomorrow